[Music]
[Applause]
this debate
is not new
it's been going on for all of my
activist life
but i'd say that
the cancer culture moment
is much more pronounced today than it
was say 30 or 40 years ago
there's always been a dilemma
within
free speech
about what limits there should be if any
where do you draw the line
do people have a right to say whatever
they want
in theory in a democracy they certainly
should
but obviously if you're inciting
violence
if you're making false damaging
allegations against people that are
untrue and and harmful
if you're engaging in threats menaces of
harassment then that is not legitimate
free speech
now
in the past
i have been involved in
quite a few
council culture campaigns
in the 1970s
i was involved in the anti-nazi league
opposing the neo-nazi national front
which conducted
quasi-terror campaigns against black and
asian communities and i thought that
that was absolutely right to no platform
those extreme fascists who were
threatening and menacing our minority
communities
in the 1990s and the earlier part of the
century i was involved in many campaigns
to cancel
islamist preachers
who have been given invitations to speak
at our universities
even while they were saying things like
that men and women should be segregated
saying that
jews deserve to be killed
that
sufi muslims or shia muslims depending
on which sect they were involved in
should die that they were apostates they
were heretics heretics
um saying that lgbt plus people and
women who have sex outside of marriage
should be executed
and i make no apology
for
supporting their cancellation
because of the
ideas they're expressing which are
beyond bigotry beyond hatred but
actually advocating endorsing glorifying
violence
i think there are possibly
three
red lines
where free speech can be legitimately
restricted
one is making false damaging allegations
such as someone as a rapist a tax
fraudster a paedophile and so on
um
when they make
actions or words that amount to
harassment menaces threats and
intimidation
and when there are incitements to
violence
those are
i think not legitimate free speech
grounds
but of course
today's council culture
often goes way beyond those limited
grounds in terms of deciding who
can speak and who can't
it is important to hold people to
account
if people hold hateful or bigoted views
they should be challenged they should be
protested against but i think that in
terms of limiting their right to speak
denying them the right to speak that is
you know a step
that is i think being interpreted much
more widely than say 30 or 40 years ago
now cancer culture is often described as
a problem or a crime of the left
but it's equally
one of the right many of you all
familiar with the recent example of gita
hari
on gb news
who took the knee
in solidarity with black lives matter
and was cancelled by gb news you know a
right-wing news outlet
so
it isn't simply
a left issue or a woke culture issue
what is interesting and i think perhaps
disturbing about cancer culture
as it is often practiced
is that it frequently involves
misrepresentation
or distortion
and fabrication
so for example
i was denounced and there were attempts
to cancel me on the grounds of racism
because i was involved in a campaign
called stop murder music
this is a campaign against eight
jamaican reggae and dancehall singers
who were advocating the murder of lgbt
plus people in jamaica
and corresponding with their music there
was a huge spike in vine attacks and the
killings of lgbt plus people in jamaica
i was told by some black activists that
this was a racist campaign against black
people black music and against jamaica
it clearly was nothing of the sort the
race of the singers was irrelevant it
was their incitements to murder which
was the issue
uh likewise
when i called out islamic extremists who
are saying that women
who
defy
traditional islamic laws and
moral codes
should be beaten
should expect to be killed by their
families
and indeed those who have sex outside of
marriage
should be executed
i was told that was islamophobic
that i was
colluding with an anti-muslim witch hunt
well again
there was no demonization of muslim
people per se
it was targeted narrowly and exclusively
at those who advocated these violent
crimes
against other people and in particular
against other muslims
the shocking thing is the prime victims
of islamist extremism
are not white people like me but fellow
muslims and i have dealt with many many
cases here in britain of
honour killings or attempted on killings
of muslims
by their own families or by extremists
the left
and i say this with some regret as a
left wing of myself
the left is often silenced about this
indeed not only silent but when people
like me
champion these causes
we are denounced as
islamophobic and again there were
attempts unsuccessful
to cancel me on account of that
another example is some years ago i
signed a letter
condemning violent attacks
and
threats in the debate about trans issues
and women's rights
the letter simply said that it's wrong
to resort to violence that these debates
these discussions these disagreements
needed to be dealt with in a civil way
there was nothing in that letter that
said a word against trans people
yet because i signed that letter
i was deemed to be transphobic and
colluding with transphobes and again
there were attempts
to cancel me
now none of these attempts
have ever succeeded
so i'm not playing the victim here you
know i fought off those attempts but
others have not been so lucky i think of
the iranian feminist and communist
mariam namazi
who has had not only attempts but
successful attempts to stop her from
speaking because she's spoken out for
women's rights
against islamist extremists in defense
of muslim women
a culture she herself comes from
another thing is that
a lot of the cancer culture
often ignores the intention
[Music]
and the context
so
people may say things
that are mistaken or wrong
but it's clear from their history and
background that they never intended to
say that
so for example sometimes people will use
the wrong pronouns
not because they're trying to misgender
people
or deny their gender identity but just
because they didn't realize the person
was trans or non-binary or gender fluid
but they will often be called out and
denounced
in a very very harsh unforgiving way
because of a genuine mistake if you look
at context
i can remember
in the 1990s when the lgbt plus group
outrage that i was involved in
sought to reclaim the word queer
it had traditionally been used as a term
of abuse and a put down
but we sought to reclaim it
as a symbol of pride and affirmation
but often when we
used the word queer
in a positive context we were still
denounced as colluding with homophobia
now quite clearly if someone calls me an
effing queer
that is a derogatory insulting and
homophobic intention
if i talk about defending queer human
rights
celebrating queer culture i'm affirming
i'm celebrating i'm supporting that
so
when we look at what people say
the context in which they're saying it
and the intention is so important
but often when it comes to cancer
culture those factors are ignored
often there's also
a rush to judgment
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you